[Musik]
selber ich will sich soll saftig was
dich gegen den favorit und durchgesetzt
ich habe mit deinem chef gesprochen das
ist mit meinem chef gesprochen ja diesem
herren mit der tiefen stimme
er meinte der zulassungsbescheid vor die
universität wäre mit diesem preis kein
problem
du kannst ja studieren selber und ich
werde ein kredit bekommen und mein
eigener praxis auf und bekommt den
kredit ja lippe wirkt für mich plötzlich
ist die familie gonzales keine schande
mehr
wir bauen uns etwas hier auf unser leben
geht weiter und es wird besser als
jemals zuvor
ja was immer er sagt selber ich musste
ja noch etwas sagen
[Musik]